what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so in a video that's actually going
to be coming out because I've already
recorded it but in the video how Jordan
wanted is part of Jeff John's Green
Lantern we are going to make reference
to the idea of Kyle Raynor's really his
source of power being what's called the
star heart and the more I thought about
it because in that video I basically
said hey look we'll do that as a totally
separate explanation we'll get into Alan
Scott or something like that you know
and kind of make sense of all that the
more I thought about it the more I felt
like that's something that should be
done before the house orden wanted video
comes out and so we're going to release
this one first so technically speaking
when that video comes out we're going to
reference a video that we've already
done while saying I will make that video
at some point online so what I might do
is I might go ahead and just like switch
them around in the playlist so this all
sorted out and that it all makes sense
but the fact remains here really the
star heart is kind of an interesting
concept in the realm of DC Comics and
the reason why is because it's really
just kind of a rework of the traditional
Alan Scott Green Lantern origin now Alan
Scott's a character that confuses a lot
of non Connor book readers when it comes
to Green Lantern in this instance we're
really kind of talking about an updated
origin that basically reflected back to
an updated origin which is really kind
of weird but to make this easy to
understand back in the 1940s really 1940
itself with all American comics number
16 when Alan Scott first appeared there
were no other Green Lantern's it was
just him he was just one of the many
heroes that popped up as a result of the
success of Superman and what do you see
did is they basically just said he got
his powers from just a mystical flame
that comes out of a lantern and that's
it I mean there was that's all there was
to it now he would use his powers really
for a pretty basic stuff and he was
usually quite with his bare hands so his
powers would be used to like move
objects put out fires or something like
that and the only weakness he had was
wood wood could penetrate the little
shield that he made around himself and
his ring couldn't affect anything made
of wood and so because of that you know
he was pretty par for the course in
terms of your basic superhero design
that we saw back in the you know the
late 1930s going into the 1940s and
really the early 1950s now all of this
changed with the introduction of Hal
Jordan and the reason why is because of
the fact there by the 1950s comic books
were moving away from superheroes and
delving into
science fiction and what's more science
fictiony than super advanced technology
and weird looking aliens and so because
of that what DC did is they said okay
the green lantern as you knew him from
as Alan Scott is no longer part of the
equation he's gone he's vanished he's
never to be seen or heard from again
instead you get Hal Jordan and how
Jordan does not get his Green Lantern
powers from like a mystical green flame
instead he got his Green Lantern powers
from a ring that was fashioned by the
guardians of the universe and the
guardians of the universe made this ring
so that Hal Jordan alongside a multitude
of other Green Lantern's could all
basically be the police force of the DC
Universe and that was pretty basic I
mean we got to see how Jordan conjure
like hardlight constructs and now I'm
Scott had done that to you to reduce you
know to a degree back in his early
comics he had conjured objects and
that's really where the Hal Jordan
concept came from conjuring hardlight
constructs giant pliers and you know
boxing gloves and fists and all
different kinds of things you know
baseball bats and so on but the idea was
he was part of an interstellar police
force it was more science than it was
mysticism now the way did you see
reconcile these two things when they
brought Alan Scott back as they said
well Alan Scott is the Green Lantern
from a place called Earth 2 and so in
that different universe there were no
guardians of the universe there were no
mystical beings or no no you know
guardians of any form or fashion
it was just mysticism that gave him the
powers that he has and so they could
basically have two Green Lantern's from
two different universes and it worked
out it was perfectly acceptable fans
understood exactly what was going on the
problem with this came when DC launched
crisis on Infinite Earths
and the reason why was because of the
fact that crisis on Infinite Earths was
designed to eliminate the multiverse so
we have that video here on my channel it
was designed to get rid of the
multiverse in its entirety and instead
what it was designed to do was create a
singular universe called new earth now
for most people in DC's colleagues that
worked and most of the DC landscape that
worked perfectly fine you had that man
who got a new origin Superman got a new
origin all the old members of the super
family were wiped away that was pretty
much it but Hal Jordan and Alan Scott
were still relatively popular I mean I
wouldn't say they were going you know
hand in hand in terms of which one was
more popular than the other but there
was a desire to see Alan Scott come back
and his comics were selling and so DC
couldn't simply just throw them away and
so what they did is they had to sit
down and they said okay look if how
Jordan is the most popular of the Green
Lanterns then that means that we have to
make Alan Scott's powers fall in line
with Hal Jordan we have to basically
make them similar without taking away
from everything that made Alan Scott
identifiable and so what they did is
they kept the idea of mysticism but they
introduced something called the star
heart now this is just a quick little
one-page explanation it's not super
complex it's pretty basic but what we
end up finding out here is that before
the Guardians had made the Green Lantern
Corps what they had done is they had
basically gone through and they had
essentially you know tried to make the
universe ordered and structured but one
of the goals was to get rid of mystical
energy now the weird thing about this is
DC basically says the Guardians got rid
of magic which we know does it make any
sense because there's characters like
zip Tana and all different manner of
magical you know heroes and villains in
the realm of DC so how this quite fits
into that I don't know and we're not
really given an answer to that all we're
really told is that the Guardians had
basically grabbed all the magical energy
and the universe combined it into a
single ball and locked it in the heart
of a star and so that's where the phrase
star heart comes from now the issue with
this is that this star because it was
basically imbued with magical energy
became sentient and when it became
sentient it realized that despite the
Guardians best efforts the Green
Lantern's might fail any number of
villains could rise they could overthrow
the Green Lantern's could kill them all
as we saw how Jordan do during Emerald
Twilight and so what ended up happening
is the star heart basically cast off a
piece of itself and then sent it roaming
around the universe looking for someone
to basically imbue its power somebody
worthy of being a host for the star
heart and so when DUP happening here is
this energy landed in China which is
where Alan Scott picks up and so what it
basically does is it breeds the origin
of Alan Scott closer in line with the
Green Lantern mythos without basically
taking away from what made the Green
Lantern the way it was and so this is
the reason why you know when we go
through Geoff Johns initial Green
Lantern run he'll actually change a lot
of this stuff so that Alan Scott isn't
imbued with like you know the star heart
and have mystical energy I said
eventually Alan Scott will be able to
form hard light constructs and he'll be
a traditional Green Lantern now in terms
of how this rolls over into Kyle Rayner
Scot basically had a daughter named Jade
and Jade inherited you know his ability
inherited the star heart that kind of
thing
and that was a source of power for her
and so what ended up happening is that
with Jade and Kyle Rayner eventually
coming together eventually Jade was
killed but in her final moments Jai
basically took all the power of the star
heart and put it inside kyle rayner and
so in a sense in essence a Kyle laner
basically has all the traditional
abilities of a Green Lantern like Hal
Jordan he's got the Green Lantern ring
he can create hardlight constructs he
can fly he can do all kinds of stuff but
he also has this star heart energy
basically all the energy that was locked
away or all the magic that was locked
away by the guardians of the universe
when they made the Green Lantern core so
he's basically imbued with magical
energy and Green Lantern powers that's
why he's so uber powerful he just has a
ton of magical energy and Green Lantern
stuff that's really all of this
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
um I don't quite know how to explain it
any better than that so because of the
fact that by the time that story was
written or at the time the story was
written DC hadn't really explained it
too much Allen Scott had gone see would
like a litany of origin retellings I
mean there were origin stories that were
just wild there was like I think there
was an origin story post Infinite Crisis
there's an origin story before Infinite
Crisis there was an origin story after
zero hour crisis in time I mean they
just kept retelling his origin over and
over and over again but I believe and I
may be wrong about this if I am feel
free to correct me although I probably
don't have to tell you but as far as I'm
aware the most recent origin of Alan
Scott basically said go read Secret
Origins volume 2 issue number 18 from
1987 that's pretty much what it was man
that's really what the origin seemed to
announce here was basically just
retelling this origin story as it had
been given to us in terms of the star
hard energy and that kind of thing but
anyway yeah so I figured I'd go ahead
and bring this to you guys basically the
star heart is just all the magical
energy in the DC Universe that's being
wielded by Kyle Rayner in conjunction or
the Green Lantern ring that's basically
what it is um but you know I could have
said that in that video but I kind of
felt like giving you guys some context
in terms of why it's that way and
basically explaining it would have done
a lot easier would have got a lot better
for helping you guys understand
everything that's going on with regards
to what it is a Jeff challenge grabbing
and what he's going in and all I kind of
get stuff but anyway um if you guys are
Gerta comments explained make sure you
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob Court you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later please
[Music]